[music]
>> This training program again is mainly
technique based.
We will try our level best inshallah.
That's point number 12.
To impart to you the techniques and
strategies of practical Dawah.
Point number 13.
One of the objectives
of this training program
is to develop your skills
in the area of doing maximum Dawah
with limited knowledge.
For example, it is more important to
know the answers and replies to the 20
most common questions than to know the
replies
of maybe 100 questions which are rarely
asked.
Spending your time
in knowing the answers of the 20 most
common questions will be multiple time
more effective than knowing the answers
of 100 questions which are rarely asked.
As far as these last few points are
concerned, does anyone have any
questions?
This is the heart
of the training program.
It is the core. It's the core.
The three things to become a successful
die
or to acquire success in any good work.
Number one is Allah's help.
Number two is striving in his way.
Number three,
it's asking the person who is
knowledgeable.
Are these three points very clear?
Any doubts?
Any
query?
Here's the summary.
As-salamu alaykum.
I got a question. You was uh talking
about hard work. But there are some
people saying smart work is much more
better than hard work. If we find a
smart work, if we find a way that we can
do in a smartest way, why we want to
choose a hard way?
The brother said that if you can do
smart way, then why do the hard work?
That is number three.
Ask the person knowledgeable.
But
if you know the smart way,
for example, you want to do 10 points,
and
you have sought Allah's help,
and maybe you're taking 10 days to do
it.
Now you know the smart way to do it, and
you're able to do it in one day.
So that is nine days you sleep.
Will you get success?
A person who can do 10 days work in one
day, what does he do?
Allah says
"The person who is a forgetful."
You strive in Allah's way. The moment
you finish the work, strive again.
So if you got the smart way, okay, now
I'll relax. Fine, you got it.
You'll only get the 10 points.
You got it?
A person
who reaches and gets the technique,
when he realizes okay, what I could do
in 10 days I'm doing in one day,
now might as well have worked for 10
days and get 100 points.
Points is subjective. It may be in terms
of money.
We as Muslims talk in terms of reward.
So person who is a very good
businessman, maybe he was working hard
and he was earning maybe $100.
Maybe in 10 days. He realizes if he
changes his job or uses the right
technique, he earns $100 a day.
But then if he stops at that, he will
not become Bill Gates.
Fine.
You take the life of any successful
person, good or bad.
I have a passion
that whenever I come to know this person
is an expert, I like spending time with
him. Irrespective his expertise would be
haram.
Note my point.
Even if he is expert smuggler,
he's working hard.
Allah says ask the expert. Not that I
want to smuggle.
There is something he has done.
THE UNFORTUNATE PART IS
he's a fool.
He's using that expertise for thing
which is haram.
So Allah has given each individual
some knowledge,
some expertise,
but they're utilizing in the wrong way.
When people tell me you quote Quranic
verses, I said you sing songs very well,
I can't sing songs.
They can sing 100 songs from this movie,
that movie, name of the factor. I
cannot.
Allah has given you a memory, but you
want to memorize songs.
You have got memory. So if he becomes an
expert in any field,
it's my hobby,
I would like to know what is his
unique point, irrespective that act is
good or bad.
We as Muslims
who know
the good and evil,
take the expertise,
but utilize it for a good work.
And by Allah's grace, I have met many
experts in different fields, good, bad,
and ugly.
I appreciate he had me, this man,
he has been internationally recognized
for something, even if it's bad.
There is something you'll always find.
You name me one person
who's an expert and has not done hard
work.
Yes, he inherited
wealth from his father, that's it.
He's not an expert.
You meet an expert actor.
The work he's doing is 99.9%
haram. I would yet like to ask him about
why is he What is he doing? And you'll
find that
all of them,
almost all, they are hard workers.
The work they may be doing is haram.
Please make a note of that. I'm not
telling you to follow their work.
But there's something in them that they
have not reached that level
unless
they're dedicated.
They may be dedicated for the wrong
thing.
When you meet the top people,
most of them they sleep less.
4 hours, 5 hours, knowing very well it's
not good for health.
I being a doctor I know
that minimum 7 hours is required for a
person to sleep.
I know that.
>> [clears throat]
>> Doctor says 6 to 8 hours. 8 hours is
correct. 6 is the minimum. The
cardiologist say if you sleep less than
7 hours, chance of you dying is early.
Alhamdulillah for the past
I think from the age of
maybe 20 from the time I'm doing medical
studies. For the past 30 years,
on average I've been sleeping, on
average, about 3 hours a day.
Knowing very well
it is medically harmful.
The doctors gave me a warning already
about 5 8 years back
that minimum you have to sleep for 7
hours. Inshallah, I'll try.
But I fear that I'll lose the reward.
What I'm doing is wrong,
but because I'm doing for the cause of
Allah, Allah makes it beneficial.
And normally for giving talks, I always
see to it that I at least sleep longer.
Average 3 hours means sometimes I sleep
for 1 hour, sometimes 4 hours, sometimes
5 hours.
Which is not good. I'm not asking you to
copy me, please.
Even yesterday,
yesterday I made a plan at least in this
Dawah training program, at least I'll
sleep for this training program at least
8 hours.
So previous days I was working hard.
But
for it to come on stage,
the first day I slept for about 2 hours.
And yesterday again I slept for less
than 3 hours.
It's not good. It's not correct.
But it's striving, and it is Allah's
help.
If you're doing it only for the sake of
Allah,
for me, as far as my life is concerned,
I know that today in the world
there are tens of thousands of Muslims
who have multiple times more knowledge
than me.
I'm not even a drop in the ocean. I
sometimes think
that why do so many people come for the
talk? What is it I've done? I don't have
knowledge.
My knowledge is
less than a drop in the ocean.
If I have to think, the only thing I can
think of,
which is not even anything great, that
maybe I strived a little bit.
Maybe I sacrificed a little bit. What
have I done? Nothing.
And what I sacrificed a drop, Allah gave
me an ocean.
Allah says in the Quran,
you give a loan to Allah, Allah repays a
beautiful loan back to you. 10 times,
100 times. One place Allah says 700
times. Surat Baqarah, chapter 2, verse
number 261. You put one grain in the
cause of Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala, Allah
Subhana Wa Ta'ala gives you seven years,
each year bearing 100 corns. That means
700 times. In business terminology,
70,000% profit. I don't know of any
business in the world
which gives you 70,000% profit.
Allah promises.
So very important is striving.
If you know the key,
that's fine, you can help 10 people in
10 days.
You realize I can help 10 people in one
day. What do you do? You relax for the
next 9 days? What difference that make
to you?
You get the same.
Or maybe you'll get less. That Allah
gave you the knowledge and now you're
relaxing.
Allah says the moment you finish the
good work, you start again.
You should be at rest after that.
After you are finished, then strive. And
to your Lord turn your attention. And
you ask Allah's forgiveness.
The moment you finish with the good
work, strive again.
A person who is a true moment
keeps on striving,
irrespective what the result is.
But Allah promises you that if your
striving is correct, you will get
results.
And the best example in Muhammad
Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam, the means he
had was nothing. And the result we got
today
is mashallah about more than 2 billion
followers. Alhamdulillah.
>> [music]
>> Allah
Allah
>> [music]
>> Allah
[music]